- It's big news that Bill
and Melinda Gates are getting a divorce,
especially because the
couple does not appear
to have a prenup.
But the thing that I kept seeing
in all of the news articles reporting
on this divorce is that
Melinda Gates in filing
for the divorce said
that their marriage was
irretrievably broken.
Tons of people have
locked onto that language
but I'm sorry to report that
that is just simply the
standard for a no fault divorce
in the state of Washington
where they are filing for divorce.
To get a no fault divorce in Washington,
one of the parties has to
allege that the marriage
or domestic partnership is quote,
irretrievably broken.
That's just simply the law.
It's not salacious in any way.
That's just simply what you
have to allege to get a divorce.
So, sorry for those looking for drama
that's just the law and
I'll see you in court.